I have so much advice to give to this
generation don't move to Hollywood the
poor with the promise of a lucrative
touring show in a Star Trek franchise
the Deep Space nine
wait a minute you did that yes hook up
when I stand with a Ferengi who gives
you an STD they you let go for so long
that when you finally go to a Planned
Parenthood in Hollywood California that
doctor says why did you let this get so
bad a doctor in Planned Parenthood and
Hollywood cover was shocked by what he
saw actually was a lady lady doctor but
that's but yeah so I had so much to
share but then I said what kind of cash
we talked about and they said oh no it's
a honnor
well sometimes with a hunter there's a
honorary em yeah and no so I went to my
business advisor who is my friend Jack
occations
you don't usually get paid to speak and
give a commencement speech you're not
supposed to get paid I googled it like
Katie Couric
she got 80 grand to speak at UPenn yeah
would I've given two of these speeches
and have been given nothing nothing I I
just gave them my wisdom and they were
like good job see you later a hole
that's all that happened ya know so you
looked it up and so they offered you
nothing I don't think so when did my
business adviser who is a former
aluminum siding salesman le occation he
lives in South Milwaukee Wisconsin the
father of a friend of mine he said never
say no without a number that means if
you don't want to do the gig anyways
just throw out something ridiculous
right and then that way either get the
money or you don't have to do it and so
I said I remember their initial offers
zilch I counter-offered with 20 grand
and their email and response was uh I'm
gonna paraphrase oh geez no way
wait a minute okay so that sort of a
thing they didn't have a stroke don't
you know and I know they did you know
they do have fundraising specifically
for a nine hundred million dollar new
athletic facility
oh he did your research yeah good for
you okay
and so um then I you know was the
University of Minnesota suggesting that
I could not get paid for the one thing
that I paid them to teach me how to get
paid to do yeah that's pretty cool
yeah turns out no they gave me ten grand
Oh all right so you they offered you
nothing if you went to in at twenty and
then they came back at ten yeah and
Elliott said I should have said you
should you should have said split the
difference at fifteen that's settled at
twelve five yeah Elliot doesn't know
everything I know he knows the aluminum
siding business but doesn't know
everything what did you do with the
$10,000 you did something kind of cool
right I wrote checks to Sallie Mae and
gave it to kids in the audience because
I but to pay their student loans pay
their student loans but the thing is is
that that's not the greatest just in
terms of that's the only way I can do
things that are kind and if I do it in
public and it's being recorded because
my husband and I are atheists but we're
nothing if not ethically competitive
yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you